one of the themes or strategies of the Republican
party under the current administration is
projection, right?
It's accused others of doing what you do.
It's a very common tactic, but it's really
been a sort of on steroids under the current
administration.
Now this isn't new.
They've been doing it for a long time.
It's just taken on a particularly sort of
special significance under Donald Trump.
Hillary's information security's terrible.
She can't be trusted with, with, uh, documents
and a classified information.
Trump is using unsecured phones that he refuses
to have screened and his family is using private
email for government business.
Oh, projection, right?
Trump is going to stop cronyism and he's going
to drain the swamp.
And then he hires half of his immediate family
and fills his cabinet with rich cronies.
Uh, you get the idea.
But on the Ukraine, Joe Biden's story, they've
actually been doing one of the most acute
projection jobs that we've ever seen.
Donald Trump and his family ourself enriching
from the presidency.
But he insists and he accuses Joe Biden and
his son, Hunter of self enriching from Biden's
former vice presidency.
Don jr went on TV, like I told you last week
and said, I wish I could make millions from
my dad's presidency talking about the Biden's.
But of course, Don jr is making millions from
his dad's presidency.
Only the blindest loyalist could miss the
reality here or someone who's cognitive new
limited and that wouldn't be something to
make fun of.
I mean, if that's the case, then you wouldn't
necessarily understand the nuances of what's
going on.
And it has now been scaled up once again to
these cartoonish levels with Donald Trump
criticizing Joe Biden for supposed ethical
lapses involving helping his son Hunter get
a privileged position while Trump is simultaneously
plugging Don Jr's new book off of which he
will of course make a whole bunch of money.
Um, Trump says Joe Biden helped his son, Hunter
make money from Joe Biden's vice presidency
is bad, it's corrupt, it's terrible.
And then Donald Trump tweets quote, my son
Don jr is coming out with a new book triggered
how the left thrives on hate and wants to
silence us available tomorrow November 5th,
a great book that I highly recommend for all
to read.
Go order it today.
Um, first of all, the idea of Don jr writing
a book is absolutely hilarious and I'm going
to get to that in a second, but this is Trump
again, doing the thing he criticizes others
for.
If Trump were any other federal employee,
but the president, this would violate ethics
rules that Trump is using the position of
the presidency to benefit his son financially
exactly what he is accusing Joe Biden of doing
for Hunter Biden.
Now, as far as Don Jr's book is concerned,
I looked around to see whether Don jr really
wrote it or whether it was ghost written by
someone who can actually write.
There's no other name listed on the book,
but I took one look at the beginning and it's
pretty damn clearly written by Don jr because
it is some of the worst writing I've ever
seen.
Let's check out an excerpt.
This is just cringeworthy bad writing chapter
one, trigger warning.
I'm not mad.
Look, everybody is called the trader once
or twice in their lives, right?
Everybody gets falsely accused and wrongly
investigated by the FBI and has to testify
in front of Congress for over 30 hours answering
the same stupid politically motivated questions
over and over again, don't they?
And everybody has an army of social justice
warriors combing through every word they've
ever said online to find something to be offended
by.
Correct.
Why should I be mad?
I'm not mad.
In fact, my plan was to write a feel good
book about forgiveness and healing, sort of
a chicken soup for the political soul type
of story.
I was even going to call it koombaya instead
of triggered, but it seemed that title was
already taken probably by one of the 2,467
Democrat candidates currently running for
president.
So instead of chicken soup over the next 300
pages or so, I'll take you on a tour of all
the craziest, most destructive ideas that
the leftist come up with in the last decade
or more.
Think of it as a trip through Jurassic park
only instead of dangerous dinosaurs.
You get to see sleepy liberal losers, socialists,
crybabies and hypocritical politicians and
media.
If you decide to come along, I promise that
nothing will jump into the car with us.
You'll also get to find out a little about
me during the ride, if only as a way to dispel
the conspiracy theory on the left that I was
born with horns, of course, horns, a known
antisemitic trope.
I mean, I hesitate to even bring it up.
Not suggesting that it's deliberate, just
always seems to end up in there, doesn't it?
Anyway.
Can you imagine being so confused about reality
that in the limited lifetime you have the
number of hours you have on this earth is
ticking down, right?
You choose this as a book to read and in truth,
no real readers would read Don Jr's book.
It's just not the way that things work.
This is not the type of book you sell to people
that read regularly.
This is the type of book you sell to people
that don't read and are going to buy it as
a political statement.
Now, as far as Donald Trump promoting the
book while criticizing Joe Biden, a, Trump
has no ability to feel shame.
He has no ability to understand irony.
He has no ability to understand hypocrisy.
That's not news.
That shouldn't surprise us.
Please, if you have some other position on
buying this book and you plan to do it, I
want to hear from you and I want to know,
I want to know why, quite frankly,